pyew do redemption - wait this launch is
a YouTube video hold it right there
looks like you fell for my little trap
you want to play Pew redemption right
I'm glad but in case you have not
noticed the game is for free
whoa let's look at this model it looks
like I have freaking Lyme disease not
that there's anything wrong today why is
everyone saying that I ruined their
childhood wait this is the Lego menu why
is this the lego starwars menu I've
already broken the game good game good
game
I don't understand why it's free they
should charge people with all right
let's see if I can not break the game
here we go alright I like the merch
that's very nice and I like the weapon
it's a giant P that's always good
my nose is fine don't worry alright
that's cool so many different people
here incredible such a diverse crowd
guys what does that indicate how long
have you playing it's Steve hi how do I
cook whoa did you see that Steve I have
to admit this bar has more appeal than
my entire ski blocky world what happened
to your knees Steve you gotta get that
check that one man I can force push
chairs what all right I'm just gonna
wreck this up alright so here we go pew
Dex whoa I got special
jump and then jump strike all right cool
let's go got a craft some more garbage
today nice me I'm collecting a Lego clay
this is the embodiment of the why
basically this is what I picked a level
cuz this is not what I understood when I
play Lego the first time whoa okay
alright
let rip freaked go it doesn't look that
bad
barrows Oh God okay I see
I lost life actually reminds me of
podracing is this is another reference
I'm confused what is it saying subscribe
oh god I'm gonna crash deja vu I have
been in this beige spit for the boost
there's nothing three out of 68 thanks
wow they're flying now they fly now they
buy now cool what how does that it's
pieces Christ
I lost all acceleration please don't do
me like this
are you serious am i in Iran is that
what's happening
I got a zigzag up almost there is this
it
alright now we can get some speed thank
you I must have stopped supposed to stop
for gas I don't know
oh wow oh no oh no what
I didn't I'm not doing that again I'm
not doing that again
pew the redemption pew do poor torture
torture alright we're back in the menu
that was a lot of fun
hey look it's donkey my is video game on
majeure and I make videos on tuber
troopers what'd you make - bird
simulator that's that I call right
nice little reference alright so we know
we store not to go into sanic Ark that
sounds cool I'll play that I'll play the
Santa cart I'm down there we go gotta go
fast question it is still relevant
goddamn Jerry's ass am I supposed to
just be run this is that the song I
think is playing that it's playing hey
yeah that's pretty good I like it
yeah alright got it here we go again
I know that reference Wow I'm not sure
what I'm looking at
it feels like I'm playing of weird
modded version of a game
am i running backwards yes no I can't I
don't know if I'm running backwards good
indicator damn speed I'm actually
running the right way I would say
probably like best game I've ever played
unfortunately tuber simulator poop the
PD PI to the legend of the brofist
PewDiePie's pick sterling overcome
before it it's crazy right thank you I
did it I actually did it
I don't believe it I can't I literally
said it
no copyright law in the university's
gonna stop me no one's gonna stop you
buddy where you going buddy
you look familiar do I know you yes it's
me I'm your biggest fan
Lyme disease PewDiePie no all right I
heard that my brother will star in a
movie
Wow can't wait to see it you have no
eyeballs so you can't but of something
more too many mushroom tomorrow too many
missions I've done that one superpower
your arc sanic arc sub war arc o
sub war oh we're bringing that up again
are we
hey look it's the fan our library living
teacher pass
hey we got the G pill what is it called
t drink sponsored guys what a perfect
time to transition to today's sponsor G
fuel and I are celebrating one year
anniversary and to celebrate for you
guys we have Boca wavin Fogo what does
that mean buy one get one pewdiepie G
fuel Cubs are now buy one get one 69%
off
fans can select two three to five tubs
or chose a second pub in any G fuel
flavor they want what total price of two
tubs 47:15 check out the link in the
description 69% off I expect everyone
for real if you haven't tried the
pewdiepie flavor I love it I drink it
every day it's so good there we go let's
keep playing
hey they got my figure e look at that
I'm so proud I got one of these so cool
anyway moving to Japan and still haven't
figure it out huh how to take a break
for dummies they should put in here
that's my setup alright very nice they
got my old so this is fun looking around
Congrats were surprising a hundred
thousand thanks alright let's head out
what is that
181 thank you thank you bro I'm not even
180 in this wait wait let me see if I
can there we got two meters thank you
thank you
alright we're collecting all the G fuel
tubs I believe nice carpet it did end a
long time long long time ago what thanks
for nothing
then you article paths uh-huh that's all
mechanics
[Music]
a bit a bit dramatic but I understand
it's a video game
alright it makes sense to play the game
to find out thanks game logic thank you
very much
Japan I'm coming I'm trying why do you
hate me Japan I just want to be in you
hey we got the little Italian flag that
means this is my stairs office she gets
the tiny desk because she's tiny she's a
tiny person not sure she's even real all
right we're heading out a million
dollars dead or alive hey we got the
theme oh yeah nice it's good mix bride
Oh God
we're fighting again test I can't do
that man god dammit
how am I supposed to fight them with
this thing the Infinity P or infinity PP
very nice great anything else can you
let me move now thank you please I
haven't done anything but yes it makes
my do that's cool and all but how am I
supposed to stop them I'll figure down
hey I got headphones good luck thanks
Harold Brian thank you so much oh god
it's already happened oh wait oh I see
the sub cam I didn't see anything I'm
ready
Thanks Anke I couldn't have done it
without you why you're such a great guy
this is a great person Oh God not the
Tesla's damn it Rex what are you doing
oh it's a sub I knew it
I'm freakin knew it this is so outdated
oh it's a big one
here's the exit can't go any more some
BOTS where are they
there they are chair [ __ ] do you feel is
that it I think no we got to get the big
guy
you're weak oh hey we got it supper now
[Music]
thank you thank you
may the memes be with you oh god that's
a lot of
they're 19 thank you very much
see if only I had some buckets thanks
for being there friend
there's more of them they just hit
subscribe overnight that's hilarious
I have to kill them all that's alright
chair share nice alright we're good to
go pretty juicy
it's kind of weird hearing yourself no
that's my car
oh here we go with game I face the same
problems in game as IRL I knew it what
alright let's go for this sub once more
dots more thoughts share share I don't
believe I am not even for one second
there's a lot of sub BOTS I understand I
get the mm-hmm I get the gist alternate
universe beauty pie things could have
been so different guys no no no this is
my Redemption I'm too tall for this room
what's happening I can't think I can't
enter here what the hell is that Slender
Man slender son
maybe now Oliver what Oh networks ok
it's almost like they don't have a
single real subscriber I know they're
all robots it don't make sense
I appreciate the obvious signs telling
we were a stand there yeah like the
developer and clearly knows how stupid I
am
what the hell here we go hey they got
swords illegal they may have swords but
I have PP Oh Dan it's a lot of them now
Jesus it's got more lens flares than the
related Star Wars film Jesus they really
went on oh look at scratches over his
body
Jesus damn it I'm running out of time I
really like how it's different it's now
or never again times three what is that
screaming in agony and what was so
scared I'm gonna break the game oh it
works all right oh my god amazing
well there's memes everywhere really
this shows just how sale memes have
become I understand it sold mass
produced mass manufactured I understand
what the game is trying to say I'm just
I'm a speedrunning I'm speedrunning
share
I can't speedrun half again where were
you when Club Penguin was killed
oh my god it's the Pierre News
headquarters from everyone where's that
sexy pooch Papa Gloria well is there an
eight oh it's infinity peepee got it yes
yes yes now yes loud and clear what I
like this guy trying to hit me he just
can't do it I'm ready my peepees ready
oh my god what are we gonna see in there
can man see
there we go the last battle oh my god
there's too many of them there's no way
I could do it but I am PewDiePie and I
have get all the Lego coins
I didn't oh cool no no this is minecraft
TNT stop them get all the butts more
dots more dots I love this sound good
what am I doing here can I destroy it
whoa Jesus Cher oh it does have a health
bar I just didn't see it you have to
look up there look there we go yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that's alright they always make the
blink the beeping louder than the boom
did you hear that boom no but I hear
that beeping no time edit then I mean
well done how can I say anything else
I'm gonna go on a limb and say Inc you
did everything like in disable ads for
399 that's a fair price
wait whose Inc Oh is inky a friend from
work thank you for making it all right
we haven't done that super pareo heart
very curious what's about that Wow
alright maybe now we can get more coins
to actually buy something can i double
jump i can double jump this is like
terraria this is just like terraria my
god are you kidding me okay
the controls are interesting Oh for
[ __ ] sake they're so annoying it's
like I'm controlling butter that's
melting from
thing to everything there we go I got
the speed I got the momentum sewers I
made it
damn that was well hidden I'm not gonna
lie I like the music I think I will mem
one Cantina if you know what I mean that
ramen oh my god I love ramen it's not
minecraft chest oh oh oh oh it's so is
that a reference
it's a bright Oh what is it why does it
do that I think I broke game no I made
another lamb
all right Neela Steve I think that was
it for a pew pew Redemption pewter
Redemption that's it thanks for watching
hey though hey hey what break no you
haven't been training on pixels we'll
get on it cuz ranked PvP matches are
live don't call yourself a gamer unless
you're up here in PewDiePie's picks
links climb the tiers get Fame points
make 19 year olds cry and unlock new
arenas epic oh did I mention there pics
links
you're welcome
[Music]
you